[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show I'm
going to keep my Preamble short so we
can get to the meat of this conversation
with my guest today Rea B burkhoff he is
the chairman and CEO of lion tree an
independent investment and Merchant Bank
advising and investing in
transformational CEOs and the companies
they lead Rea founded lion Tree in 2012
during a time of unprecedented
disruption and since then lion tree has
supported an expanding number of
Industries as they capture opportunity
and involving digital economy we're
going to touch on a lot of those points
Rea is also the founder of Kindred media
a digital media and podcasting company
powered by lime tree and serves on the
boards of Yahoo and Carnegie Hall before
founding lion tree I spent 13 years at
UBS closing his tenure as Vice chairman
and head of America's Investment Banking
before UBS Ra was a high yield research
analyst and ranked as the number one
cable and satellite analyst by
Institutional Investor for seven
consecutive years Rea is a graduate of
the University of California at San
Diego and resides in New York City with
his family you can find lion tree at
liontree.com and on Instagram you can
find a number of accounts at Rea
burkhoff that's spelled
a-r-y-e-h-b-o-u-r-k-o-f-f at lime tree
underscore LLC and at Kindred podcast
Arya welcome to the show nice to see you
thanks so great to see you thanks for
having me of course of course I've been
looking forward to this and I wanted to
start with actually a mention in your
bio so ranked as the number one cable
and satellite analyst by Institutional
Investor for seven consecutive years
what makes a good analyst or what made
you a good analyst and what are common
mistakes that analysts make
well it takes me back
you know a career has different chapters
to it right I actually think those
chapters should be related to one
another and foundational in nature but I
don't like to hover in one place for too
often
and I also don't like to think about
the zero-sum games so things I'm doing
today have no relationship with things I
did before but I'm glad you brought up
this Analyst job because I think a lot
of people forget about that part of my
life but it was so core
in training
and also in the relationships and the
understanding of how to be not only a
good purveyor of companies but also of
my own
emotional stability I would say and so
the way I would say that as analysts is
often thrown around but you know it
could be like a therapist an analyst but
in this case a research analyst which I
was as someone that really looked at
Securities or stocks or Bonds in a
particular industry so for me the
industries were always media cable
telecoms technology consumer driven
companies and uh at first I looked at
those companies from a bond perspective
junk bonds high-yield bonds and then
equities stocks and the high yield bonds
was the first part of the research
analyst role I had but then covering
stocks covering you know public stocks
in those same Industries and covering
those stocks in those same Industries
allowed me to ultimately get to a goal
of helping investors
make money with those recommendations
now how you do that is understanding the
company
it's fundamental picture and ultimately
where it's going in the future because
everything today should be understood
and everything tomorrow should have a
lot of uncertainty around it so pattern
recognition how to predict the future
is the first thing that you really are
supposed to be learning as an analyst in
order to help inform the masses of which
Investments to make
but then the emotional stability part of
it comes into play when you get out in
front of everybody
and say with some boldness and some
prose and some analysis
here's my view I think I'm right
more often than not you're wrong yeah
and it's like watching two kids in a
schoolyard when you were growing up
getting into an argument
and you watched one of them clearly lose
that argument
and then count down until you saw that
they recognized that they would have the
confidence to admit that they lost the
argument and there's always a lie it
could be 10 seconds it could be weeks
could be years
and that's all about like capitulation
and so the first thing I learned was
when I was wrong and I thought that I
would be right
to quickly recognize that I didn't have
anything that was that interesting or
different to say in front of everybody
and by doing that it was very
embarrassing and it could even be minor
things but it built so much credibility
later
that when you are right
it counted so much more and for so much
more and then it built your own
self-confidence that you really did have
something and then if you're really
lucky and that's where the rankings come
into play
when you say something that's different
than the masses
and you have the confidence to say going
against the grain to predict the future
then the markets will go with you the
investors will go with you people will
be profitable based on your
recommendation people will make money
based on what you say and you build a
reputation and that was a process
so this raises a number of secondary
questions well the first just for
clarification when you're talking about
taking a public stance and
promoting or publishing an opinion what
form does that take is it a is it a
ranking system is it a general sort of
binary buy or sell recommendation just
for for folks who are listening to have
a more discreet understanding of what
that opinion looks like
what form does that take it has to be a
published report
that has to have an initiation report it
could be a report on the industry so it
has to have some perspective some
thematic and within it some specific
company recommendations so let's just
say I want to write a report on the
movie studios and then within that
report I would say here's my view of the
movie studios and specifically my
recognition on Disney and Warner
Brothers and Viacom at the time and Fox
at the time and then you said and then
Within These these are my
recommendations buy hold sell and
supportive documents and then because
you knew that no one would actually go
and read a hundred pages
you'd have to summarize it in a
perfectly synthesized four bullet point
cover page and before any of that stuff
happened you have to go through internal
processes to defend your arguments uh
where people internally have the right
to say we don't really think that works
but more often than not they would let
you go and let the public be your
ultimate judge and juror
because that public embarrassment will
be far more damaging to you and that far
more self-correcting than anything they
would say internally but they have
obviously institutions to to protect but
those documents were full of analysis
and thematics and contacts both contacts
of the here and now and the past versus
the future but the ultimate goal is
breaking the future if I said to you Tim
today is let's say Monday and by Friday
I was going to tell you based on certain
pattern recognition what was going to
happen to these stocks based on my
analysis or maybe better a year from now
and you believed me because of my
credibility and our relationship and we
had a track record together
and that conviction level was high
then you may invest just based on my
word
but at the beginning you value to do my
own research I'm going to read your
report then I'm going to check it with
other people's reports my own conviction
level
and then I may even go counter to what
you say maybe I'm a counter indicator
sometimes but hopefully you are the
indicator and and then obviously over
time if you're right more often than not
you just start investing for yourself
you may not give it to everybody else as
a service
that's the motion of a career right well
that is your Evolution it's not always
Evolution right playing with your own
ships and taking that
responsibility to make direct bets in
that way is is not a leap that everyone
makes and I want to take a step back for
a second just to read
a fantastic headline this is a piece
from The Hollywood Reporter so how Arya
burkov became media's hottest deal maker
so some of the groundwork that we're
laying right now is going to lead into
that
but I wanted to mention that because it
is an exceptional piece I thought it was
a very entertaining piece also that
people should check out
let's rewind to Alan Ginsburg not the
poet different Alan Ginsburg but who
who is Alan Ginsburg and what are some
of the lessons that you learned from him
Alan givesburg gave me a shot
and uh he was
a mentor and the person that first hired
me into this thing called Wall Street in
New York and remember I came from
California had no reason to be anywhere
near this industry or Wall Street didn't
know anything really of substance coming
out of University except what everyone
else knows which is like how to
communicate look for a job maybe how to
write a little bit
other people maybe have much more
vocational expertise in engineering and
Medicine than I did but I did I was a
generalist coming out so coming to New
York didn't know a soul
and basically put resumes under
windshield wipers you know said like you
know here's my flyer I have an interest
in being here
I'll hustle and I'll earn it and then
you have to convince people to give you
a shot and Alan Ginsburg gave me that
first shot and when I interviewed with
Alan who himself
was and is a we're still in touch a
creative person in finance because
Alan's background even though he was a
lawyer and financier and so on he also
wrote for Rolling Stone magazine he
liked writing he liked the way the world
worked
and he wasn't a traditional person you
think of as uh you know Gordon Gekko
Wall Street type you know and so maybe
that's why we took an interest in each
other because we talked about how the
world's working he gave me a chance and
so Alan hired me and and he said I
remember he said you're going to be the
first person that works for us in the
high-yield bond group at Smith Barney
and Alan ran the Smith Barney research
group having come from bear Stearns
before that and I think before that he
was immediately a Drexel Burnham in Los
Angeles the Michael milk Ohio bond shop
and uh and I said okay great I'm gonna
work for you what do I do
and he said uh you're gonna help me
cover the industries that I focused on I
said which of those Industries and he
said it's media it's Telecom it's
technology it's food as restaurants
yes and I said well I I have no idea
what you just said but I like to eat and
like to go out to eat in restaurants so
that sounds good eventually those fell
away and I kept going with those media
and Communications and Technology
industries from day one and uh and then
I just decided to get that competitive
streak to be
better than the rest and to work at it
and I eventually got the bug but I
remember thinking to myself watching him
in action I will never be able to be as
good
at communicating as he is or as good at
analyzing companies as he is and he just
kept uh going at it until you eventually
uh
get the groove
so two questions related to what you
just shared the first is why go from
California
to backpack in hand to Wall Street and
even make the attempt what was the draw
or the reasoning there and then secondly
why do you think Alan gave you a shot
why would he say yes why would he take
that
the ostensible risk
I was in California at the University of
California in San Diego as you mentioned
and um
I knew as I was graduating that I
wanted to get into the center
of Finance
like I didn't want to stay in the
periphery so if you're going to go into
an industry go to the heart of it don't
plan on the edges why the interest in
finance also why Finance it all this is
the way I describe it to my parents who
are academics and looked at Finance I
could tell in a disdainful way like
that's not a way to live your life maybe
a lot of your listeners think the same
way and I thought to myself okay I have
to present this to them I remember going
to travel to see my mother
and I said I'm going to go into Finance
and uh this is the way that I think it's
a worthwhile way to live your life and I
just because they were like academics
and professors and so on and and I said
entrepreneurs people have hopes and
dreams that sometimes take the shape and
form of businesses
and those businesses need money Capital
to see the light of day to realize the
dreams
and that's Finance
and if I could play a role in helping
those individuals get capital and have
their dreams realized that is a
worthwhile Life to Live
sounds like a good pitch right yeah it
sounds like a good pitch your picture I
mean that landed well and uh I mean I I
got the blessing plus I was rehearsing
you know probably practicing my
interviews so that's really what I
believe and believe to this day and
that's kind of what makes it interesting
you know you see the energy in someone
else that you're able to recast the
problem as a solution
that is based on someone's real idea
and it's not just about moving pieces
around creating something new and I
think that it was enough for my parents
but it wasn't enough
in New York because a lot of people have
that pitch I think like I remember like
when I was in college I went to some of
these parties and um you would walk in
with your friends and like the vibe
would happen and I remember walking with
one of my college friends and like he
couldn't get any women to pay attention
to him and I remember he said to me one
day he goes I don't know like you know
my mother always says I'm attractive
I remember thinking to myself I also
like so I passed a test with my mother
about my fish but when I got to New York
it didn't really land as well it may
have landed but it was in competition
with a lot of other people yeah and so
it took me about four months in New York
to get to Allen because the day I moved
to New York was because of a job
interview and I thought I had to Jackpot
like one of one like I'm the day I
graduated was a Sunday and I think
Monday or Tuesday I had interviewed
an interview Shop with a guy named Paul
Tang I don't mind saying it now he's
probably out there somewhere at
Oppenheimer and he covered the oil and
gas industry
and I told myself I wasn't going to
choose the industry whoever hired me
first I would just be loyal to that
industry for the rest of my life and I
could build a specialty and so I went
and I
incredibly I got this interview and I
had a meeting like this day two in New
York
downtown
the big city it was 1995.
and I thought the interview was great
and I was gonna be a research analyst
working for Paul Tang oil and gas
Oppenheimer
at the end I was you know starting to
like start out of the office and say
okay next step when do I start you know
this is like the same interview I had
with my mother like it's Landing well
you know and he goes by the way one more
question he goes do you know the uh
programming language Visual Basic
it's like C plus Visual Basic and I said
no
and he said um well I kind of need you
to know that if you're gonna be on the
team these days they call it a doorknob
negotiation like on the way out as
you're holding the door up it turned
back and say by the way one more thing
that's the whole negotiation yeah right
I don't know what we're saying do you
know the Visual Basic I said no
and he said um well you're gonna need to
know that for me to hire you I said well
what if I learn it and master it well
then you hire me he goes yeah yeah then
we're good
that's New York City I was like great I
left bought like Visual Basic for
dummies bought a laptop drained my
account and got supplemented apartment
started learning everything two weeks
later felt comfortable this is the world
as it should be you know called up and I
never got a return phone call
oh man and I was like well what do I do
now
by the way while I was at UBS in a
senior position in research I did see
across the tape probably I don't know 15
years later that we hired a guy named
Paul Tang at Oppenheimer to do oil and
gas for ubf when I was there doing media
and I wait till he started and I went
down the hallway
I knocked on the door I said by the way
Paul you may not remember me I want to
welcome you to UBS
at this point I was an established
senior person doing you know media
stocks
really well established at UBS and I
said I just want to welcome you and I
want to tell you that I've mastered that
[ __ ] Visual Basic programming thing
and uh I wish you luck here buddy
so like even then you put like an aside
one of your philosophies it was like the
toe you step on today could be connected
to the ass You're Gonna Kiss Tomorrow
so yeah Alan four months later
left in New York I became a professional
job Seeker
and I would basically walk
to different buildings that looked like
you know hitter buildings and I looked
at the directory at the basement at the
lobby level so it looked like Wall
Street firms the ones I recognized
obviously and then others I didn't
recognize and I would go up this is
before where they pre-911 they didn't
check IDs I would go up to the HR floor
I would hand in my resume and I would
choose a different location of Manhattan
every week to tackle
the downtown the Midtown and then one
day I stumbled upon you know Smith
Barney it was still on Greenwich Street
downtown right across you know from the
Grand Hotel like this is now like an
amazing hot area back then it was like
away from Wall Street or away from the
action and Kareem krennic to her credit
because I'm naming names was the HR
person that led me through the door and
it gave me a shot whoever she is and
interesting to Alan get his work and uh
and then by that point I was pretty good
on the pitch
and also self-corrected like knowing
what didn't land and what landed
and Alan gave me a shot I think you know
he liked the hustle he liked hustle
liked the background probably and also a
little bit of luck but he also called me
I was a [ __ ] I do remember he asked
me what my the proverbial Question
Interview is what's your weakness yeah
and I do remember I said remember that's
when I was practiced so I said my
penmanship
that's pretty clever and he said uh
he said that's uh that's a [ __ ]
answer
try again
so then I had to figure then I stumbled
through it but then I um we both
chuckled and and I forgot what I said
exactly but I'm sure I said something if
that was more sensitive but he called me
out on it you know yeah amazing
well it seems like perhaps a blessing in
disguise life-saving you from what you
wanted with Paul and the oil and gas but
who's to say I suppose in retrospect
I want to take a closer look at Alan
teaching you how the world worked
and I'm looking at
a kindred media piece on medium
and there's a mention of Alan and
I'll just read part of it which is one
day Ginsburg asked him that's asking you
if you read the paper
thinking uh what deal did I miss what
happened did I miss a number
are a reminisced Ginsburg goes no no no
forget the numbers the opera house
burned down in Florence you didn't read
that
and I said I didn't even think to read
that and then he said you're going to
have to be a little more open-minded
about this and the reason I bring this
up is that observing you in person and
also doing research
in preparation for this conversation you
more than almost anyone I've ever met
tied together
many many many many disparate worlds and
you seem to have pattern recognition not
just in one sector but across sectors
was there any other
World educating that comes to mind and
that could be through direct teaching or
osmosis observation that came to you
from Alan or other mentors
I appreciate that you said that because
it's much easier in life to stay in a
box
and
a blanket a compartment
of the whole ecosystem and and by the
way there are places
for people to be in those boxes and to
thrive in those boxes
when you start to move outside of that
box
or the in the corners of that box or the
edge of that box or outside that box so
draw
outside the lines so to speak
it is a beautiful place to live and it
is also a dangerous place to live
because it's full of unknowns and
uncomfortable Maybe
groundbreaking things
it reminds me of another philosophical
line of uh conventional thinking is
typically right but seldom profitable
that's great
feels good to think like everybody else
and to be moving with a herd but you're
not going to make a difference
you could be wrong but you may never
really be right in an outsized way if
you don't really stretch into the
unknown
and some people are not comfortable with
that but where do I get that from I mean
I get that from everybody I mean but it
really goes back to
self
work ultimately you have to have a
strong core
to be able to do that
because if you just move with the wind
outside the box then you don't really
know who you are
so just to interrupt for a second so by
having Clarity on that core or solid
core is that if you wouldn't mind I
start to interrupt but just expanding
that for a second is that a core set of
values a clear idea of what you will or
will not do so that you don't end up
conforming
to whatever wins happen to be blowing at
that moment
yes yes it reminds me of the scene on
Raiders of the Lost Ark
that last scene where the evil spirit
comes in to the warehouse and Indiana
Jones and his compatriot or his partner
or his girlfriend whatever at that point
they're all intermingled are hanging on
to a foundational pole with their eyes
closed
but yet this Spirit comes in and
completely uh you know
destroys everything else and and kills
everyone's faces and it's a horror scene
right but they survive right and they
survive because of hanging on to this
pole hanging out to each other
and keeping their eyes closed and just
hoping their way through it and
obviously the metaphors that are good
and everyone else is evil and that
Spirit recognizes it right
but I think about that like you have to
hold on to a few polls
you can't just be floating around you
have to have a few poles of foundational
strength
that you believe in
that are making up your core
and
those are tried and true
but at the same time that allows you to
be curious
self-adjusting
self-corrective
migrational around other areas and being
comfortable with many different types of
people
that are not like you at all because you
have that core
and that creates a very balanced and
texture life and existence
and a way to build pattern recognition
and perspective that most people would
be locked in pursuing
and by the way I'm locked in my own way
too like everyone has certain blocks
right
but the more of the that exercise that
you can do the more of a perspective you
can get of where the world's going and
where it looks like to be a different
cultures while you're living in your own
foundational strengths and values and I
think to me that that all goes back to
the basic Foundation of
self-awareness
self-worth self-correction self-growth
and once you have that like you're a
member of society that's valuable
and then you look for that in others and
run away from people that are
ignorant or biased or you know morose or
also maybe a nicer version of that is
just want to go with the flow everywhere
yeah and don't feel comfortable with
some out of the box thinking because
it's threatening to those foundational
values a way to say that from a finance
perspective is when I was a research
analyst
I wouldn't feel comfortable putting a
buy recommendation on a stock
before I hit the send button until I
both felt the conviction of the buy and
the rejection of the cell
so I had to live with the cell
recommendation inside of me first for a
while she even felt comfortable or
uncomfortable
and let it in
left like the poison inside for a while
if that felt too comfortable for me I
couldn't a good conscience go to the buy
so I had to have a buy and the rejection
myself because the Buy to me could have
been a passive recognition not an act of
recommendation right so you have to ask
yourself are you comfortable going into
a controversial scenario
or do you want to just live in the
non-controversial you know
one more question on this core
is this a let's just call it a general
imperturbability
or a solidity that was more a felt sense
for you or was it something that you at
that time codified in some way you're
like I prioritize these five things or I
will I resolve to follow these following
values was it codified or was it more of
a felt sense of stability
and solidity
for you at that time
both they're interrelated so
the first time I remember feeling that
sensibility was probably like in grade
school
being popular kid with the friends
everything not an outcast like with the
group but a little bit different
and feeling inside a little different
and then the question is like do you
feel bad about being different
or does it start to empower you
or both
and I kind of felt like well let's test
it out
and I remember thinking I
am very happily situated where I was in
eighth grade but let me leave that to go
to a new ninth grade school that was an
unknown away from all my friends
and let's see if the friends were the
thing that made me feel great or the
inside was the thing that I could apply
to new friends
and keep that train going
and uh I chose to apply it to the
unknown and chose a brand new place
and left behind what I had before
I wouldn't do that with like family
or like the like a very close
relationship but I felt very comfortable
doing it with the environment I was in
to get myself in a new environment and
knowing that it's me
that can adjust and apply my skills to
different areas and not the environment
around me that defined who I was
I could be more proactive defining
environments versus having to Define for
me I remember that back then and it's
happened a few different times in my
life whether it's moving different
places or feeling comfortable I always
say I
feel comfortable everywhere but belong
nowhere
that's a geographic comment and that's
true by and large
but I also have done that in my careers
where I feel after a certain amount of
time in one area
move
take these strong parts of what is
applicable maybe the industry knowledge
into new areas the learn learn areas
than I didn't know before and see if you
can reconcile those two things and then
that builds that core
with the unknown together that's a life
of curiosity and creativity
but also life of foundation and strength
and contribution on the other hand
that I call that like the gray area like
you are comfortable in the gray area I
feel like that's a competitive Advantage
for me I can hang out in that gray area
longer than most most people in the
world very comfortably until I see
the optimal scenario to pass on you know
let's talk about
perhaps that gray area maybe misapplying
that term to what I'm going to ask but
this this relates to a story you told me
last winter
and
if you don't want to discuss this I
can't imagine it's sensitive but we can
we can all also cut it afterwards but I
think it came about because of the title
of my first book four hour work week and
someone said oh you should talk to Arya
because that is probably not going to be
a a driving philosophy or something
along those lines although I do think we
have some similarities as well in terms
of per hour output and thinking about
various things and you told me a story
I'm going to get some of the details
wrong so I'd like you to correct it but
about at one point realizing that many
meetings were being declined because
your calendar was full and then deciding
to take an entire year
to block out every Wednesday I can't
remember from like 6 to 10 p.m or
something to take all of those overflow
meetings that were being canceled could
you could you retell that story if you
wouldn't mind
so it all starts with the concept of
rejecting constraints
on one hand on the other hand problem
solving which is like probably one of
these terms that are thrown around so
many times problem solving I'm a Problem
Solver I run a company I don't solve a
problem and it's probably like but like
who actually does that put yourself in a
situation where you actually solve a
problem that seems insurmountable so one
of the problems were time
I don't have enough time time being the
constraint let's just tackle solving
that problem
because everyone just talks about that
all the time
and the other part of the story is
the passive or active conscious or
subconscious deprioritization of people
that are let's say not as important to
you
as
your kindness Gene wants them to be but
you're really not going to put them on
your calendar or the prime spots
right so you de-prioritize them and then
if you are prioritizing them in your
mind and your heart and your body and
your soul
your office will de-prioritize them for
you
and people have become an expert at
these things right now over time you
build
a luxury in life of being able to do
that and being more selective because
as you mature you want to spend time
with only things that are Central uh
maybe running out of time but when you
first start a company
and we first started a company with
relationships
at its core
and with reputation that's really
important to define the company
the concept of rejecting people for
those relationships in any form
is out of the question
so what would happen at the beginning of
a firm
some 10 years ago
was I recognize that I was a funnel
people would want to figure out what's
going on at one point in time there are
very few things in your life that light
up all your contacts at one time
like let's say your wedding your funeral
God forbid
like maybe a big job movement a big news
item imagine and like all of a sudden
your phone like lights up right but most
of the time it just kind of Smooths out
certain people want to care about
different things when you start a
company
it will light up everything on your
contact hopefully or if it doesn't you
have a bigger problem right
and so this was a company starting based
on all of the relationships in my
contact base
at a place to put them and to cultivate
them to build a skyscraper
at the beginning it was just me and the
relationship with an assistant
and so I started to get wind of the fact
that certain people couldn't get on my
calendar which is obviously natural
because you can't put every single one
of your contacts on your calendar at the
moment you announced a new company even
if it's like a few weeks out
people are gonna say sorry you can't
make it but imagine how that feels for
somebody else
I want to support this new lion tree
Venture and what are you doing oh but
you can't see me
what a horrible way to start a company I
don't care who you are
so I after a while of reading
and hearing people sending me notes or
emails
I recognize that there are certain
category of people that they were
because obviously the office New enough
to give them credit to prioritize you
know the Tim ferrisses of the world
right away right but
they maybe prioritize things that would
be like immediately like dollars
oriented or transaction which was also
not the philosophy of the company but
they wouldn't prioritize things that
would be career advice or people that
wanted to work with the company as a
vendor or business partner or things
like that
that they wouldn't even know but I would
know so I brought the assistant into the
office and I said um so what is this
thing we're rejecting people they said
well you don't have time I said yeah but
you get paid to say yes
I can say no that's the job of the
assistant to figure out a way to say yes
and they said but yes but Arya you don't
have the time on your calendar
and I said well that's the questions
let's figure out the problem solving of
time now
what have I created a whole extra day in
the week
without unlock the potential for filling
in all these kind of
second tier requests so to speak
there's a yeah I mean hypothetically if
you had a whole extra day we probably
have a lot more to work with I said okay
let me think about it
um
I got it
Wednesday night you're right Wednesday
nights but the hours are different from
10 p.m till 2 A.M
from year one of the company I will do
office hours but no internal complaining
is that no no internal like [ __ ]
sessions there's no like suggestion box
this is an external session If people
really want it that bad
I'll be here no one else internally has
to be here just leave me a little food a
little drink and let's see who wants to
be here I'll be here and then I'll start
the next day at same time
yeah seven in the morning eight in the
morning whatever I'll I'll eat it I'll
eat it on my end for a year and I think
that'll apply unclog the situation and
we've created what you've viewed as a
constraint of time I created a Time by
eating into my my sleep hours
so your four hour work week is really a
four hour sleep week for me
but it works it worked people showed up
for a year until two in the morning I
know the most interesting grateful
conversations that's just like New York
City at its finest like you know in the
office you know you're talking about
life and careers and then that paid
dividends not business dividends but
like
you know reputational benefits and
Humanity benefits like who are you what
do you want to be the other day and I'm
happy we did it I don't regret for a
second now I don't do that now
I would love for someone else in the
company to do that now
because I want I'm in motion still and I
I want to be more selective and deep
with relationships versus volume
oriented right now
and I almost like want people to compete
for the depths of those relationships
with me versus the masses
but that's what the firm is supposed to
be to understand what is selective
versus
but the firm needed at the beginning to
really understand what we're about yeah
Amazing Story wow 10 to 2 A.M so two
questions how did you choose 10 to 2 A.M
was that just to uh
separate the Casual inquiries from the
true believers
that's question one how did you choose
ten to two and then the second you
mentioned something that I think
probably caused a number of people to
perk up because it was it would be the
opposite of what many would perhaps say
and that is the assistant's job is to
say yes you can always say no I think
assistants are viewed by many folks as a
as a protective layer maybe a flak
jacket to deflect as much incoming as
possible
so I'd love to hear you just explain why
10 to 2 and elaborate on the assistant's
job being to find a way to say yes
tentative is easy because I want to
leave room for
dinner yeah not dinner you know God
forbid like a personal Journal a client
dinner like a dinner with outside you
know like a business in life for me are
very well integrated so it would be use
the city and go to dinner and then after
you're gonna come back I used to
probably some people still bring this up
people see me down the street they say
are you are you still doing three
dinners a night and I'm like one time
maybe like 10 times but then two times I
would do that I would go to two dinners
like I was just trying to get it all in
and you know not eat as much at each
dinner and move around and probably in
retrospect didn't wasn't the best thing
to convey to people but except for the
fact that I was working hard and trying
to make sure everyone was happy and that
I would get it all in but this ten to
two was about making sure that that
night I would have room for my dinner
meeting or out of the office using New
York great City to do that and then
coming back to the office enough time
and then starting 10 p.m and then I want
to have enough time
there's this great song uh
I think it's a YouTube song
that has a line that says like the magic
hours are when it's it's not yet the
morning but it's still night
but it's not really night time you
haven't started thinking about your next
day yet
but it's past normal nighttime for
everybody else right so you really can't
be bothered and none of us really live
that way I think day to day but that
must be where a lot of magic happens you
know and then you get to a point where
you start thinking oh my gosh tomorrow
morning my calendar is this and that
that to me starts around two in the
morning
and so if I went past two I'd start
eating until like what I have to start
doing the next day yeah
no problem we could put in the show
Notes too yeah yeah yeah that's a great
song
oh yeah when the night has no end and
the day yet to begin when the moon
builds around I Need Your Love it's hot
moon rising and Rattle and hum you too
I'm a Rattle and hum out was the only
place you could find it I think Rattle
and hum YouTube Half Moon good memory
there you go and the assistant
the assistant the complexity of the job
of an assistant particularly for me or
for anyone in a relationship business
that
towards meaningful and there's a long
build to it and a long tail to it as
genuine
is probably the most complex respected
job
in the company
and
it is a puzzle piece that is
I always think of it as like those
images of broadcast television when
you're like okay I have Thursday night
must see TV and what's going to be the
six o'clock hour or what's going to be
the seven o'clock what's the eight
o'clock hour and how's one gonna lead
into the other and how's it going to fit
and are people going to be still watched
at 10 o'clock when it's over and what's
going to be the show after the Super
Bowl you promote you know like how the
calendar flows and behaves
is like a living
breathing
animal with a soul and a brain and
everything else and the people that have
to
construct that every single day today
and into the future
the assistant
I think is I respect that brain power
and that knowledge more than anything in
some cases including my role
so
if you start with no
instead of yes then you've you've kind
of stopped playing the puzzle you know
you said I can't fit the puzzle piece so
it's not going to fit somewhere but if
you say yes then the puzzle keeps
expanding and the calendar has to mimic
the strategy of the firm where I want to
be going the changes in the development
of the firm the change of the people I
want to play with work with
experience life with
and the understanding of that has to
mimic one another and so it's not they
say yes I say no it's much more of like
we understand where we're going and it
has to reflect the kind of reflect uh
the vision of what's going on in my head
and and therefore have to be
communicated that way and it has to have
a yes around it somewhere and dig it
yeah thematically makes sense I I want
to hop to UBS here and
I'll tell you one more thing about the
counter by the way because this one is a
lot like um if you boil it down
internal meetings
everyone has a ratio so like if you did
nothing
because of your reputation and your
brand and your substance
your calendar is going to be full people
are going to want to get on your counter
all the time without you even choosing
who you want to see
that's I call like defense and put that
aside for a second and then you had a
blank sheet of paper and said forget
that calendar I Tim want to choose
exactly who I want to see
and that may not fill the whole calendar
every single day but it'll be proactive
it'll be offense it was defense one's
offense everyone has to create a balance
of those two things in their calendar
who wants to see them and who do you
want to see and that mix and then
there's the intro versus the external
and there's no way around the fact that
internal meetings
are cost or investment doesn't be
negative it could be you know but
they're necessary investments in the
company or cost and external meetings
should be Revenue
or you know potentially for your future
Revenue so one's Revenue One's cost
if your calendar is 50 50.
offense defense
or external internal or Revenue cost you
haven't done anything
yeah again you're running in place
and so I'm very cognizant of the fact of
what's the ratio
what's the ratio
and so I figured out a long time ago I
really would love to make sure to be
like 70 30 external versus internal or
maybe 80 20.
and then you can start thinking to
yourself okay that builds a good margin
and then different times a year have
different moments obviously you're if
you're paying bonuses you're doing
reviews maybe that's a little more
internal but by and large the internal
should be more predictable if you're
managing a good organization you could
probably put the internal on your
calendar for the entire year
otherwise there's surprises going on and
there's more surprises going on the less
well-managed the company is
right so you should be able to pretty
much put the intern on your calendar
right now for the whole year and then
the external you'd be surprised at how
much external you can put in your
calendar in advance also
I'll meet you at Formula One in Austin
Tim do you want to go again this year
like this is a date yeah or this
conference or this event or this holiday
you know and you could probably put the
tent poles of your external on the
counter you'd be surprised how little
room that leaves for the spontaneity and
the Serendipity of Life which it must
something has to then give absent
sleeping hours right
and so like that's kind of what you're
playing with you're playing with these
like marginal
slivers
of space
that is growth
that is a choice
that is what different today versus last
year
and that will represent who you are
today versus last year
and what you want to be in the future
and whether the best companies in the
world is going to stay exactly where
they were or evolve there's no accident
that most people don't most companies
don't evolve you really have to work at
it the constant build you're dealing
with slivers of space and time to make
that happen
I'm glad you added that I'm taking a
number of notes for myself so that's why
I'm scribbling furiously over here
I'll cancel all internal meetings for
you by the way to see you
at a moment's notice I would go fly and
see you you know that would be like
that's the sign of true respect so thank
you for saying that I look forward to
the next time we're able to spend some
time in person and I'm very much
enjoying this entire conversation I've
been looking forward to this and
bonuses you mentioned bonuses so
and I think this will tie a number of
threads together some of which are yet
to come
but we're skipping ahead a bit but you
ran Investment Banking in the Americas
for UBS and had something like 1500
people reporting to you
when people came to you or Bankers came
to talk to you about annual bonuses
as I understand it from The Hollywood
Reporter piece you would ask what is
your Edge
and I would love to hear you just
elaborate on the function of that
question and what you mean by that
it goes back to how you're judged
ideally you're judging yourself every
single day everyone's making their own
adjustments
every single day
and then you have external factors which
reminds you how you're doing
every single day
and there's a lot of haphazard activity
and
not everything's based on logic and
reason but if you're running a business
you'd have a daily profit and loss
statement which tells you how you're
doing if you're in a restaurant tells
you what you're doing if you run a
investment fund
you know tell us what you're doing that
all those things contribute to your own
humility
and self-correctiveness right
if you're paying
somebody a bonus
or a compensation at the end of the year
you are the one that's creating that
self-awareness in that person
I've never seen anybody
come into a conversation around
compensation
and feel
as an employee that their boss
has synced up exactly with what they
think that they're worth never seen it
so within that is a Chasm of
misunderstanding or emotion
of what you think you're worth versus
what they think you're worth
on a given year
okay and that's normal life right
ideally you'd like to have some daily
metric that just defines that like that
daily p l so at the end of the year
there's no one big event
so what I was trying to do is to try to
build in
as much of that
narrowing of that Chasm as possible
before the conversation because there's
a negotiating strategy or you could call
it like a real effort to just build
awareness saying like the best way to do
that is to ask someone to Define who
they are
and you'd be surprised when you ask them
to talk about themselves
how passive they will be and how either
how little they will value
themselves
on the right way and how much they over
by themselves in the wrong way and so I
said like you know people always say
what is your superpower
maybe those things are thrown around too
often these days what's your competitive
Advantage what's your Edge
and in a certain defined role
like the role of Finance or the role of
banking I said the edge really comes
into play of you know do you have a
unique idea
do you bring unique capital
or if you have a unique relationship
but I wouldn't give them the answer I
was trying to figure out if they could
get to it if someone says I work harder
than everybody else I mean okay imagine
telling like an NFL player or NBA player
I work harder
is that really an edge these days I mean
one of these things you hear like I'm
doing the best I can I'm like okay well
then you get out of bed and then what
happens
like I'm assuming everyone's doing the
best they can what everyone says like
that you know life is too short like
well life is the longest thing you know
you know anything longer than life you
know it's like
let's just live in to the fullest as
much as you can you know yeah but then
do better than that and when you ask
someone to Define their Edge or their
advantage
you'll learn a lot about themselves
um
so was this conversation then
it was preceding the official
performance review slash decision on the
bonus this would be
a precursor sort of setting the table
Yeah months or weeks or
whatever time frame prior to the actual
conversation yes and I would rarely even
initiate it you would see people
by the way I had one this morning today
actually
and you know people want to get a sense
of where they stand
or how they're valued or what their
opportunity is
in the future all those are code words
for how am I going to get paid
it's fine
it is what it is
again it'll be better for those things
to happen on a day-to-day basis why am I
telling you how you're going to get paid
you tell me
how are you going to get paid based on
what your Edge Look at Opportunity is
and my job is to provide the platform
for you to optimize that better than
anywhere else
and your job is to optimize it here and
have the free market to choose somewhere
else if you can't do that or I can't do
that and embed within all those
Solutions or scenarios is maybe some
biases or some lack of self-awareness or
my mistakes are not building the right
platform or not managing correctly right
and so maybe as a manager of my job is
really to throw the penalty Flags around
versus manage and tell you exactly what
you're worth before I have to Once
entrepreneur Island one's needing to be
secure where's that security come from
self inside or outside
you know like when you're a parent to a
child
you have to provide that security but at
some point they have to then
get unlocked right
not everyone has to be entrepreneurial
all the way but there's certain
responsibilities that I have to build
the business for people to thrive and
make sure it's that kind of environment
Mission driven and opportunistic and a
meritocracy around that
and certain responsibilities that people
have within it
to then take it competitively better
than the best they can
and then the risk I take is that they
could do it somewhere else better than
here
but I own that risk every single day
what risk do they own
yeah well said
for people listening
I want to add a bit of color and then
ask about a specific instance
so you have been part of any driving
force behind some of the the largest
deals
I mean the world has ever seen certainly
in Media
and people might be listening and
thinking my God this guy doesn't sleep
he has endless energy it's just a home
run every time he steps up to the plate
which may in part be true but
could you please I'm gonna get the name
wrong I don't know how to pronounce this
properly but can you please tell the
deck of cards story with Joe Young
yellow is that how you say that name
correctly no I and LL uh I knew I wasn't
gonna get that right all right nothing
you got my name right and not the Jones
is a real
industry I appreciate it
well obviously what appears to be a home
run every time is not
first of all every day is full of
happiness and successes and frustrations
and consternations and irritations about
what we could be doing better what I
could be doing better frankly all the
time
um as much as introvert as I'm an
extrovert by the way I think as big as
misnomer I was like I'm always out and
about and I get a lot of energy from
being out about partially because of
other people's energy not just my own
but I also really enjoy some thinking
time with music and some reading time
and kind of a chance to re-energize
and go deeper than just bouncing around
and that you just don't Instagram out
the the periods where you're sitting
alone yeah the people only see that the
things that you're like where you're
bouncing around they don't see the
moments where you're just happily
sitting alone reading a book or
listening unless you're really not
focusing on it you know so I think uh
you know the appearances are a bit
misleading but it's the texture of all
the above
and some of that thoughtfulness is where
you really come into strategizing around
what the future could be for you for
your loved ones and also for the deal
making in the future
but in that particular story it all goes
back to this element of well you know
what you don't know we were doing a deal
I think in 2007 for the Sundance Channel
which was owned by NBC CBS and Robert
Redford we were selling the company
on behalf of the owners I was at UBS and
we really did a good job I have to say
like we did a good job starting a
company it was not an easy sale
eventually
the dolans bought it actually
the company that owned IFC Cablevision
the next bought the Sundance Channel for
500 million dollars
and I thought we did a good job and uh I
remember
in those days in some cases also today
when the job is done then you start to
think about well how much am I gonna get
paid for the services now sometimes you
get that figured at the beginning
in this case you figure out the end
we were thinking that would work to our
benefit because it was such a home run
deal
and I thought we did such a good job
that they would want to pay us more
whereas if we agreed at the beginning we
probably would have undersold ourselves
and Robert Redford did really well in
that deal remember I think I made more
money on that deal than all the acting
years combined
but it was a pleasure to work with
but CBS is CFO or even I think it was
the treasure at the time was Joe ionello
he wrote the ranks of him being the CEO
for a while after that and Joe was a
tough negotiator but we're on the same
side of the table
so afterwards I was told by my bosses at
UBS like okay are you a great job of the
deal now go get us a good seat and I
said okay I have to do that too like all
right yeah that's that's what it takes
and I said okay so I went over to Joe
was appointed as a person that had to
negotiate our fee
and I I thought it'd be like one of
these great Kumbaya conversations we all
did a great job together and let's drink
and get it settled quickly but no so I
went over to uh like a black rock you
know the CVS building has a long
conference room and it was just Joe and
myself sitting in the middle and Joe
said hey um you're here to negotiate
your fee right I said yeah
but you know you project some confidence
be really nervous inside and he said you
know just to break the ice a little bit
before you get into that negotiation do
you wanna
play some cards do you want to do a card
trick I'm getting into cards recently
that sounds great like friends now too
this is great you know me so yeah he
said let's you know what more than just
a card trick why don't we just shortcut
the whole thing since you're busy I'm
busy
and why don't you just pick out of the
deck any card
and whatever card you pick will be your
fee and we'll just do it by chance
I said really like just to clarify like
a face card Jack queen king that's like
10 million dollars
and he said uh
he said yeah that's right it's only
coming from 500 million
whatever you pick that'll be your fee
I said okay
if I reach in pull the card out and it's
uh it's a three
and he saw my face I was very
disappointed
and he said you seem dejected
would you like to do it again
I said well yeah can I do it again and
he said yeah let's do like best status
right
so that's a great like so nice gracious
uh do it again and I pick out of three
again
and I'm thinking that's terrible now I
don't remember exactly I was expecting
to get but definitely more than three
and definitely relative to the face
cards or anything else I was thinking
this was towards the bottom of the deck
right
so you guys you seem uh like you're
you're in a bit of a stuck place maybe
you want to call the home office back at
UBS and
find out what they have to say I go yeah
I have to do that I can't just walk back
with that you could use the phone in the
conference room here just right in the
corner so I went to the phone picked up
the handset
and there was a card on the handset
and it was face down I picked it up and
I turned it over and it was a three at
that point I didn't realize what's
happening negotiating with David Blaine
I said are you telling me Joe that my RC
has three million dollars because that's
what I'm telling you
he had the whole thing wired
I respected it though that's what we
that's what we got that's what we took
so negotiating is one of your
Sports in the sort of decathlon of of
deal making
that is the craft one of the crafts
you've mastered
this is going to seem like a lazy
question but I'm going to ask because
it'll be on the mind of a lot of people
listening
for someone who wanted to become a
skilled negotiator
would you have any recommendations in
terms of resources approaches
common beliefs that are actually very
unhelpful anything at all for somebody
who wants to develop their ability to
negotiate well
of course
that's probably the opposite of what
people believe or instinctively would do
which is usually the answer by the way
so I would say like 90 of time everyone
focuses on what is important to them and
what
we or what you say
it's irrelevant
all that matters is how it lands to the
other person
it's a life
in order to understand how something
will land to other person you have to
meet them where they are
you can put yourself in their shoes
once you put yourself in someone else's
shoes then you don't have to do what
they say in a negotiation but you have
to at least start with that
understanding
and then go back to what's most
important to you from there and then you
have a fair
understanding of what that negotiation
is going to look like
but if you just start like throwing your
words against the wall
is never going to end well and you're
going to be very frustrated it'll be
temper tantrums and so on I I kind of
make it the best analogy I can think of
is when you're in a huddle about to
throw a pass in a football game
and you have figured out you're going to
throw a post pattern in the Huddle and
you've thought about it that huddle
if you
you know say hi play goes and you throw
the post pattern play
but you haven't looked at actually what
happened in the field and the receiver
had to go in a different direction
you need to meet that receiver where
they are
your post pattern play is irrelevant
it's only relevant to your formation at
the beginning
but it's not relevant to actually where
the ball is going to go in the end
because what happened on the field is
much more important so like
you have to do the preparation work and
have to have a sense of what you think
is proper and right from your
perspective but you also have to
understand what will be the scenarios
that will be important to them
and then the middle ground approach was
too often used it's not that it's just
starting from understanding both Vantage
points it's the same kind of skill set
as saying before I put a Buy on
something I have to also reject the cell
you know you have to um be comfortable
in an unknown position before you can
adequately argue for your for what's
important to you and then in a trusted
relationship which is the only way to
negotiate with a trusted relationship
you're going to get down to things that
are really important and things that are
not really that important and to be able
to be comfortable saying that like okay
if I listed these three things please
rank in order for me
what's most important to you and what
you really don't need that will give me
a little bit more room to come back to
something that I think we could work
with because that shows that you'll be
able to give up something to get
something which is obviously Hallmark to
any transaction
now that's a good negotiation there are
tactics above that so sometimes in order
to get to someone that you need you may
ask for things that you don't really
want just to settle back in
to something
that is a discount to that that you only
would do that if if you feel like the
other person is doing the same thing so
it all goes back to trust
and that trust is not about one person
trusting another it's at different
phases of the negotiation that trust
picks up so at the beginning of a
negotiation it may be less trustworthy
than at the end when things are really
coming to the Finish Line when you can
see the light of day that thing you
start to pick up towards the trust so
you have to see kind of when you can
play those different tactics but then
today it's kind of putting your seeing
people where they are I think it's
really important without giving up what
you really need
let's explore that a bit so seeing
people where they are you gave the
football
metaphor
could you describe
an actual deal
situation or process it could be real it
could be anonymized it could be
hypothetical but just to walk us through
a concrete
case study
of what that
looks like knowing the other side since
you led with that in your answer could
you perhaps just walk us through an
example
all the deals that we work on that are
public
company deals end up being
filed publicly with the play-by-play of
the deal no one likes to read legal
documents
but the fun part of the legal document
is the play-by-play of the deal if
people are interested in the
step-by-step of how a deal works because
while we're doing the deal we're very
aware of the fact that it will be filed
publicly so it's not like you're pulling
fast ones because
either it's going to be disclosed how
you're doing what you're doing
so you have to be truthful there's no
concept of like lying in a deal because
it will all be uncovered later if you
want to be in the business the next day
so that's called the proxy statement and
that one section is
written up by lawyers that actually
recount the deal did not know that yeah
so what I'm going to say is public
information you know when we did the
transaction of selling MGM Studios to
Amazon
which is the only example of a Content
company being sold to a technology
company today
there was an impasse between the buyer
and the seller that went on for a while
and the the deal ended up being worth
around 8.5 billion dollars
but for months
Amazon will not go above 8 billion
and MGM
and the owners of MGM so we're not
selling below nine billion dollars hell
of high water
and so we were at an eight to nine
billion dollar bid ask for months
to the point where the deal could have
gone away like a bit you know one hand
you're close the other hand nothing's
happening
so finally the chairman of MGM who was
really dear friend
you know calls me and says I'm ready to
like what do you think I'm ready to
unlock this Gap
and I knew Amazon very well enough to
know that they were thinking because
this Gap was going on for so long that
the owner of MGM and the chairman in
their mind they're thinking didn't
really want to sell
so they're thinking that 9 billion was
just basically saying I don't really
want to stop
which I knew that was not to be the case
so
the owner and chairman of MGM said to me
um I give you my proxy
to go in there
and break the logic
and so I did when I went to call the
Amazon executive
I said okay we're ready to negotiate now
they said well there's nothing to
negotiate you know they're at 9 billion
you know we're at 8 billion and we're
not moving I said
okay I said well and they're not even
really selling the company I said well
what if I told you that they were
selling the company he said well how
would I know I said well
I'll in good faith
speak on behalf of the chairman and give
you a new offer
that will
yield a bit under the condition
that you respond to me within 24 hours
with a counter offer then we'll get the
ball rolling
so I get also the feedback back to the
chairman
that you're serious about dealing
meaning that if I could speak
for a principal you have to speak
also that you want to get something done
but I'm not going to move unless you're
gonna move I need to know that you're
going to move
and that was trust because they took a
risk that I could represent the owners
of MGM
and uh
they said um okay what do you got I said
I think we should split the difference
and go right to it but it has to go fast
and you have to get back to me right
away
and I did
and if they didn't
and in those 48 hours there's a lot of
emotion you know but they did get back
and I moved very very fast from there
so that's exactly what we're talking
about right yeah
well someday I look forward to reading
your compendium of deal stories
I would be the first in line to buy a
copy of that but before we get to the
compendium of deal stories probably a
better title to be had
you mentioned a while back reading time
and there are quite a few books
recommended in your year-end letter uh
are there any particular books that come
to mind that have impacted your thinking
recently in the last few years
or any let's just say Timeless books
perennial books that have impacted your
thinking
there are quite a few I mean I
I probably buy more books than I read I
wonder if that's the case for a lot of
people actually yeah I listened to more
books that I read
I don't read complete books but I do try
to read as much as I can
and so I'd say the Timeless books are
one book called leadership and
self-deception
it's really a book about self-awareness
that we really hand out to the firm and
it's a book about really just kind of
owning your own decisions
that's a Timeless book and the title was
leadership and self-deception yeah
leadership and self-deception there are
two like Timeless books are a book
called scale by Jeffrey West
that is all about
why some things last minutes you know
humans
could go on for 70 80 years you know the
queen lasted 96 years
the average public company goes for 10
10 and a half years and dies but cities
seemingly last forever you can throw
nuclear bombs in cities unfortunately
and they but they still keep moving
why do some things last some finite
periods of times and some things last
much longer it's about you know what you
feed it and the ability to grow it but
ultimately it goes back to adaptability
if something has a rigid purpose
and you break the purpose
it will die profits for a company will
die a city the people always reinvent
itself you know this summer
I think five governments fell this
summer
you know the UK
you had Italy
yeah Israel you had you know Sweden
recently right and you had like even
like France became dysfunctional and I
was like oh my goodness all these
governments are falling but that's okay
because if the people are unhappy and
the government don't fall
that's rigid that's a problem
governments fall it's a chance for
reinvention and just like New York City
where I'm sitting now like had a chance
to reinvent itself post pandemic
or in Detroit company town when the
industry falters
in the Auto industry had a chance to
reinvent itself with creativity or
medine and you know Colombia you know
used to be like uh known as like a rough
kind of drug trade yeah murder capital
of the world during Escobar's role yeah
that's cool technology hug artsy right
cities reinvent themselves based on the
adaptable forcing function of those
people right I love that concept and
it's very helpful for a company build
dynamic
the third one is a book called scarcity
like I I think we're moving from a
period of abundance to scarcity
and so how you are not fearful of
scarcity
but what you how you could do more with
less and we're getting into it here now
where you know there's unfortunately
scarcity of food and water and energy
resources shortages because of macro
economic
Dynamics Warfare in the Ukraine and
Russia
and I think
inequality post-pandemic and how you
deal with scarce resources people paying
their bills plus inflation
you know what you do out of those
Dynamics it creates a lot of tension and
uh fear and conflict even military
conflict
it's a different kind of read than
abundance and we have everything we want
but then on books I read now more
recently are about people
I'm beating a booked out called the
Banker's Journey about Edmund safra's
Journey a banker from Brazil just came
out I'm reading a book now
by Chris Blackwell about you know the
music industry and his founding Bob
Marley and U2 and his journey yeah
things are interesting personal stories
I read books all the time
John wenner just came out of the book
today I'm looking forward to buying the
Rolling Stone editor and founder
he and his son Gus are friends so his
son was and then Jan but interesting
life and stories
texture to read so uh I like to read a
lot and I probably read more than I
consume other forms of media
so related to the books any biographies
that really stick out for you and then
second if you read any fiction which is
not a judgment question but if you read
any fiction if there are any fiction
books that have had a outsized impact on
you in any way
biographies I mean I like all the Neil
Ferguson Books like around the house of
Rothschilds
JP Morgan books books on I actually read
a Bill Collins book on uh the uh last
tycoons a really good book not only
because of being in this business but
you do want to go back to the
underpinnings of what is like
relationship banking which I really
think that's a really interesting
profession Beyond just Finance it's like
you know
how to build with people
over a long period of time without size
impact that's I think that's really
really interesting to me and I hope
other people in The Firm and
and even your listenership
and fiction I mean I've always loved
some of the mystery novels illegal
Thrillers I've always liked the John
Grisham books
but I would say you know meaningful to
me like me and ran obviously it's not
fiction per se John Steinbeck the Pearl
at a recognition of a friend of mine
who's in the business a reread the other
day great great book
and I love The Sun Also Rises anyway
yeah great book there's a particular
line in there that I love that he's like
if we're talking about bankruptcy
saying that
it happens gradually and then suddenly
sometimes things on the way up have been
a very slow and methodical
but on on the way down
things happen gradually and then
suddenly like you there's not a
symmetric relationship between things
that happen on the way up and things
that happen the way down yeah
and then another book I would say is
David Brooks the second mountain is a
really interesting book it is uh a book
about I view it as a book about personal
development careers
people in our age of life
you know you kind of start your career
coming out of school and thinking about
what you want to do one step in front of
the other and you get to a certain point
like at our stage of life
and then you think that's where I
started from to where I am has nothing
really to do with where I want to end up
yeah top of the second mountain and once
you start thinking about that you end up
in the valley of thought
until you figure out where that second
mountain is
and when you start climbing a second
Mountain
you don't even have to get to the
destination it's just a joyful climb
it's a happy climb you're doing every
single thing you want to do with every
breath you have I love that whole
concept finding that second Mountain
there's no such thing as a linear move
from you know the day you come out of
school all the way until you die it's
not linear you're going to hit a Chasm
and it's cool until you find that second
amount to climb personally
professionally et cetera it's all good
I'm gonna buy that today I also love
John Steinbeck and I've read
pitifully little of his work but travels
with Charlie if anyone has not read that
a non-fiction account of him traveling
across the United States with his dog is
is absolutely laugh out loud hilarious
and also very profound in its hilarious
observations but David Brooks I'm going
to get that book today
so thank you for the recommendation I
must ask a a question to scratch my own
Edge in terms of curiosity and this is
related to one of your more recent
Investments you've invested Malcolm
gladwell's audio production company
Pushkin Industries per year 2021
year-end letter
and I'm a huge fan of of Malcolm he's
been on the podcast huge fan of Michael
Lewis also who's who's been involved
with Pushkin and who's also been on the
podcast and the caliber and quality with
a
produces is is I think
absolutely astonishing what do you think
is next for the podcast Market or what
would you if you have any thoughts on
where you think things are going what
trends are emerging or converging
what do you see coming over the next
handful of years for the podcast Market
or industry
the audio market and the podcast Market
is
strong and growing clearly like
everything in content
the quality has to rise to the top
because a lot of people have jumped into
it
and
have to also get curated in terms of
guys remember at the beginning of
YouTube you were in the jungle you had
no idea how to navigate YouTube it now
finally you could if you want to go to
sports you know where to go and if you
want to go to history if you want to go
to Brands Commerce you kind of know
where to go so I think there needs to be
more curation around audio and
podcasting in general
where you find different content and
when and
how you digest highlights and versus you
know the whole episodes Etc
but it is going to be more branded and
more curated I think from here and
heavily monetized but hopefully not over
monetized in ways that are uncomfortable
like I'm not anticipating things that
are full advertisements but sponsorship
is going to be more interesting
platform that will really get behind it
are like you know obviously I heart
Spotify
Amazon
but every platform that reaches a global
audience needs differentiated content
today and video content alone
has kind of had diminishing returns
audio content
and podcasting content I think that's
really well branded and curated and
quality like this one
I think The Best Is Yet To Come still
and it hasn't even scratch the service
globally and so I think those are going
to be
really interesting but I think more
curated more guides more branded content
and monetize in different ways I think
we'll be pretty pretty important and
then there's social features as well
like
some more interactivity of being able to
do events and tours and
going around to talk to your audiences
and having more of an interaction
between the fans and the creators I
think is a big white space do you have
any thoughts on how the market will move
or consolidate because I've I've watched
all this with great interest of course
and
I've looked at certain transactions say
relatively speaking heavy spending and I
will just underscore something you said
which is I think it's still very early
if you look at the terrestrial
radio
total ad dollars compared to what has
currently migrated to say podcasts it is
it is still just the tip of the iceberg
and even when I launched this podcast
and I can't recall what it was 2014
2016. I was told by folks the ship has
sailed it's too late they're too many
podcasts I just don't think that's the
case at all I was told the same thing
when we launched the bank in 2012 that
it was late to start a new Independent
Bank as a strip of sale and I was like
well well maybe we'll maybe the door
shut behind us you know they'll be
laughing
seems to it seems to be working out uh
in both cases yes and if I pick one
player for instance let's just say uh
Spotify
spending very heavily
with respect to just their say market
cap and moving into podcasts The Joe
Rogan deal valued at at least 100
million probably quite a bit more with
earn outs and everything else
my my assumption has always been that
once Spotify
accounts for more than single digit
listenership or downloads or streams for
the top say 100 podcasts which will be
reflective of broader trends that that
type of talent acquisition would drop
quite significantly just as as one sort
of hypothesis but what do you think the
movements will be among some of the
larger players because you have Amazon
you have Spotify you have
I heart and podcasts are an existential
imperative perhaps or viewed that way
for some and not others
what do you think the
the landscape of the the larger players
will look like
a few years from now
it took some of the streaming platforms
like Netflix and Amazon
and apple a long time to get into sports
for example
and now they're all bidding for sports
rights because they have to have sports
as a differentiator and once one gets in
they're all in so Amazon's been here for
sports rights Apple just did the MLS
deal
they're all looking at sports deals
Netflix has Formula One a drive to
survive right in some ways so I think
podcasting is the same thing now that
it's hitting The Sweet Spot of the curve
from a
revenue and profitability contribution
for iHeart and that was all over
spotify's investor day of like the
podcasting growth driver
then you're gonna see Amazon and all of
them jump into it and then you may see
competition for talent between platforms
and then you may start to see some of
the podcasting personalities and Brands
intersect with other genres so imagine
you're
with Amazon and Amazon's doing the NFL
and they want your post game show
intersected
with your podcast of the NFL so they're
going to start using you as a key brand
for the platform overall Beyond just the
show yep it becomes assets of the
platform that become very interesting
and different packaging of the deals I
think will be uh fascinating it all
depends on the loyalty and engagement of
your user base yep and your community
and what the community is going to be
driving yeah that they want to see and
obviously you're ability to engage with
them
I hadn't thought about the cross asset
utilization of podcast personalities but
that makes all the sense in the world
and
I have to imagine that's playing into
negotiations right now for talent deals
because they might say well what's the
size of your advertising base can your
sponsors will your sponsors transfer
over to us if we acquire exclusive
license or if we acquire you outright or
whatever it might be but in fact the
value of that that property in terms of
the personality may be much greater when
it's viewed as being possibly applied to
all these various things
I think this is pure speculation not not
investment advice obviously but
I think twitch is going to prove to be
increasingly valuable to Amazon and I
recall when the
pandemic hit I I had an an ongoing bed
of sorts with a friend of mine that we
would see
some type of platform utilization for
streaming Sports If Sports could not be
attended in person and I just think
these off-label uses of these technology
platforms and cross asset utilization of
personalities I hadn't thought about
that makes a whole lot of sense you and
I met at Formula One so imagine maybe
that's your future where you're doing uh
taking on a British accent doing the
formula one uh
it could be that in your future but um
what do you want
if you were going to migrate and take
and evolve your audience yeah into a
different genre with you what do you
think that they would be into
that's a great question I I think
I I haven't really thought of it uh in
this way I would imagine and this this
will seem very simplistic but whatever I
am
interested in I think my audience will
trust me to take a very close look at or
a a meaningful percentage of my audience
will trust me to look at which is by
Design largely I mean that's why I did a
book on physical and sports performance
after the four hour work week rather
than doing the three hour work week is I
wanted to see early on since I had this
open option to always extend the
business book side of things if my
audience much like say with a Michael
Lewis even though he's a far superior
writer
or John McPhee or Malcolm Gladwell would
they follow me because of my Approach
and thinking not because of the subject
matter and I think by and large that has
held since then
and so it would be a matter of me
determining what I am
legitimately interested in because
without that legitimate interest I won't
have the endurance
I won't have the necessary emotional
investment and endurance to make it
count in any meaningful way if that
makes sense well yeah I mean I think
that your whole Community is built on
trust yeah
and you also have
a curiosity to you as well
but based on certain foundations yep
that people sort of view you as
Dependable right they're not they don't
think you're going to Veer them off to
an extreme position yeah
but you're inquisitive about where the
world's going and my view is that you're
ultimately interested in an impact
around that yeah but not in an
establishment sort of way there's a sort
of Insurgency around it right yeah
I think we're very similar I do too
so I was just thinking about this trust
and how it's it's uh the asymmetrical
rise decline uh the precipitous drop uh
you know how it takes 20 years to build
a reputation in 20 minutes to destroy it
if you make the wrong choices uh and so
I say no the vetting process for say
sponsors and guests and so on is very
very
I don't want to say strict it's not
quite the right word but I always try to
ensure that I'm following my own rules
and not getting swept away by The Winds
of
Trend or more specifically fads right
and
this may seem like a non-sequitur and
this will be probably one of the last
questions so hopefully we can do a round
two sometimes because I've I have a lot
of questions that I'd still love to
explore but
this may seem like an odd segue but
maybe it makes sense in some way so you
were known as a goalkeeper at UBS
protecting the balance sheet you saved
them hundreds of millions of dollars and
you know I'm reading here
just a snippet from from the the piece
in The Hollywood Reporter so your job
was to analyze potential deals and
advise the bankers on whether they made
sense and that role he rejected 40 out
of 45 potential deals which and this is
my words now it didn't make everybody
super thrilled however when all 40
companies later went bankrupt
they realize that uh the higher-ups that
you'd saved hundreds of millions of
dollars
what were you doing there so you I mean
you seem to have a certain I don't want
to say presence but a
inability to see where the puck was
going with respect to the 40 that were
rejected
how did you do that
why did you do that
if I was a goalkeeper in high school
even a relatively short person I was
able to play goalie in uh in soccer
and
I think that
it all comes down to
understanding
there will be many more shots on goal
that exist today so don't be afraid to
say no to something today with a fear
that nothing's going to come tomorrow
so like the sample set that you're
dealing with today is not the whole
thing
play the long game
and so I felt that a lot of the
companies that we were looking at at
that time were coming to us because of
sort of negative selection that we were
getting uh pitched by companies that
weren't necessarily the highest quality
but just because we had capital
doesn't mean that we should do it and so
I wanted to play quality I wanted to
only do business with the best companies
and if we didn't have the structure in
place to attract those best companies
today that's our issue to deal with
but the worst thing you can do to
compound that is make bad decisions on
top of
you know fixing your own structural
issues and that governs everything even
today like when you're building the
company when you're working with the
outside world the internal world you're
making sure that you're making the right
decisions
with a quality standard for excellence
at all times
and that you're not accepting mediocrity
especially if those things have a lot to
do with your own fixes that you have to
make you know so like we spent a lot of
time doing infrastructure work
internally
and then planning for excellence but if
you're going to do one thing I prefer
inactivity
than mediocrity
I want I want to make sure that we play
for excellence in quality all the time
all the way through the company and all
the way through
the Ripple effects we have externally
and do fewer things with quality than
than scale things obviously
ultimately prefer to do a lot of quality
things
but that takes a lot of structure that's
what I called scaled intimacy if you can
scale the constant of intimate
relationships and intimate deal making
that's the Panacea but otherwise I
prefer to do just a few high quality
things and then uh and then take it easy
for a while yeah I think that's the
standard don't settle don't settle ever
but I do have to tell you one story
though because you did give me some
really interesting prep work yes please
your prep work had questions about
certain things like what's one of the
things that you purchased for less than
a hundred dollars that made a big impact
and how I would have said a book you
know so we were talking about some of
these books
but he also said anything anything
particularly interesting you've ever had
to eat or drink in your life
and I thought about it for a few minutes
and
you know there was I travel the world in
interesting places and you try to
integrate business in life and enjoy
what you're doing and appreciate the
Finer Things where you can and there's a
drink that is served
at the Hemingway bar the Ritz hotel in
Paris
that is called The Mach 2 m-a-c-h-2
and it's a really I've never had it
anywhere else
and it's a it's a whiskey based drink
with uh true sense of the essence of
Ginger and some ice it's really really
good but the funny thing about it is as
I was thinking about it yesterday and
thinking I was going to be talking to
you on a podcast
I last night went to an event in New
York
for the rich in Paris and frame uh you
know as part of the fashion recalls of
it because some friends were putting it
on and unexpectedly that bartender from
the Hemingway bar in Paris at the wrist
was at the event
and I said
it's unbelievable I'm going on the Tim
Ferriss podcast
and
he's gonna ask me about a drink and only
you serve this drink in the whole world
and here you are in New York leaving
your perch at anywhere bar
could you could you indulge me with this
Mach 2 drink
and uh he did yesterday and so I was
like it all came together this is how
like there's certain Karma to my
calendar and uh and this podcast and
everything else so and your question so
I want to make sure that we talked about
it wow that is incredible but
synchronicity and now I have to try that
now I have to try the mock too I look
forward to that I've needed to have
needed a reason to I've only been to
Paris once really in any meaningful way
so I need to get back side note that
because this took place in Paris for me
I did a lot of writing I've done almost
all of my writing for my first three
books during those witching hours so the
before the before the morning and after
the usual night almost all my writing
was done in that I would say 10 P.M to
3 AM
period almost all of my writing in those
witching hours is that when there are
fewer distractions or you're
clear-headed yeah no distractions no
distractions more energy I tend to be
like a hamster I just have a second wind
that for whatever reason for my entire
life has started very very late
and freedom from distractions silence
less
compulsivity to interact or text or
check anything because I know the rest
of the world is asleep or Mo I shouldn't
say the rest of the world but the rest
of my network is largely asleep
and it's just always been
that Twilight that creative Twilight
through which you can perhaps pull on
threads that are normally harder to
access I think for me that's been my
experience
um
well
Arya I could keep going for hours I've
got plenty so maybe another time but is
uh
is there anything you would like to add
any recommendations or requests of the
audience things you'd like to point
their attention to of course people can
find lion tree at limetree.com we'll
link to all of the Instagram handles
social Handles in the show notes so
people will be able to access those but
are there any any closing comments or
requests you would like to make before
we wind
to a close
it's been a great pleasure Tim I could
also talk to you for hours and I was
looking forward to this for a long time
and um you know as we go through
different periods of time in our lives
and the World At Large and we've all
been through
different unexpected
movements and motions and things and
that's one concept there's going to be
more unexpected things to come it's all
about these trusted friends and
communities that we can build which is
the distinguishing feature of humans
right that we can bond together for for
good things and then tackle the world
and I think if we uh if we eliminate all
the extremism then you can everyone can
redefine their view of what their
centers look like and then that's where
the richness lies and whether you find
it in the magic hours and the wee hours
of the night or the middle of the day
I think we uh we can form these circles
and then really bond together and I
think The Best Is Yet To Come and I
really appreciate this relationship and
what we can do together and I really
appreciate the attention of all of your
audience and the one thing about media
that is defined is it's the distribution
of content over a technology and when
you think of it that way the technology
used to be books newspapers
now it's podcasting it could be
different things in the future but the
best content distributed is something
that applies to everything in life that
people consume and digest a lot of music
or words of wisdom or politics
and the responsibilities on all of us to
make the best impact out of it all and I
really appreciate what this media can do
for our lives so Best Is Yet To Come
perfect place to close so Ari thank you
so much for all your time and for your
wisdom and for your stories I I have
copious notes of my own so I'll be
following up on a lot after this
conversation personally and
really
love what you're doing and the more I
read and learn of you directly or
indirectly the more questions I have so
I look forward to Future conversations
and for everybody listening
we'll have links to all resources names
books everything related to Rea and lion
tree in the show notes as per usual at
tim.blog podcast and until next time
please be safe be just a little bit
Kinder than necessary and find your
Center